have you ever seen those videos and I'm
going to speak to New York City I come
from New York City have you ever seen
those videos that pop up from the subway
where you'll see a woman being harassed
on the subway by I don't know who and
there's a bunch of guys just sitting
there watching and they don't do
anything about it what do you think is
causing that Trend particularly in
cities like New York City and Los
Angeles among men I think this whole
teaching boy is that they're equal to
women and women that they're equal to
boys doesn't help I think that men by
and large and this if anybody If any man
hears this and isn't just upset I don't
know what you are then because men are
just weaker than we were before
statistically speaking when it comes to
sperm count sperm count is down to men
60 percent when it comes to testosterone
me as a 27 year old man I'm gonna have
36 percent less testosterone than a man
in in 1980
what is it 1989.
I don't because they're putting uh
plastic in the ranch I don't know yeah
like you know like we're eating that
he's not wrong we're overly stressed
this is true